Selam
[Müzik]
bugün Burada bulunmaktan çok gururluyum
ama çok da heyecan
ama ben İzmir'in fakir ailesinin çok çok
paketi ailesinin
çocuğuydu bizim köyümüz var köyümüze
kışlık erzak larımızı almak üzere at
arabası ile gittik Annem iki kıskandır
dediler ki dönüşte kamyon mu Ay bir
heyecan bir saygı bir sevgi tarif edemem
Çünkü ilk defa hayatımda 4'te kere
biliyorum
bu ve
bu arabaya bindik gidiyoruz bizde de
pakat
kaleye kamyon şoförü arabanın içine
baktı kahve üstü açık atlı inde de
herkes haklısın trenler patladı hayata
yuvarlanıyor Annem herkese atladı patır
patır Ben anneme sarılmışım Annem bana
sarılmışım o kemiklerini kıracak
kelime-i şahadet getiriyor artık
gidiyoruz Ve sonunda bir çukura bir
ağaca İşte benim hayatta biçim Bugün
buradayım Allah yaşadıkça yaşadık
abone ol
bu
insanlar eşit doğmaz
var ama eş dönüyor
ve konferanslarında Hacı Sabancı çok
severim
o muhakkak der ki ben altın kaşıkla
doldu
Ben de satılık ışıkta durdu doğduğum ev
bu
o gecekondu dünyanın en mutlu evi yer
sofrası bir tavsiye emek
ve o yemeğin içinde et varsa biçimde
kıymaya part maharetli boy Çünkü tadını
alabilmek için
ve bu evde yer sofrasında
babaannemle çok sevişirdi o kadar
muhabbetimiz bizim iki saat Bizde bir
ayakkabı alınacaksa kredi kartı olmadığı
için O sofrada hesap yapılır
Babam anneme derdi ki her akşam bir
malzeme olur nerden bulur nereden eder
lamada Legend Magic yeşil gözlü kalıcı
Anlat Bana bu yüzden ayrılma boyu var
Asi Daralıyor
Allah Allah özel 44 senedir Ben eşimin
elini bir gün bırakmadım şimdi kızımla
elini öpüyorum
bu dünyanın en büyük lokantası'na gitsem
umrumda değil Çünkü o bende bir anneanne
o
ama sıra bana geldi babam bizim de
tutardı benim sofrayı uzağındayım diye
koçum dedi Ataşehir indirme
o Bende ses yok koştuk
hüngür ağlayarak
bu kader Peki bulmuştu
ve yaşı gelmiş ilkokula verdiler çarptım
otur dediler oturdum kalktım
bu ayakta Kökü mü olmanın Alayı
Dilmen'in Kanunen suçudur ama vicdanen
ve çok çok suçu vardı onun için
hayatında kimseyle alay etmem Allah
dolayı etmeyi nasip etsin ve dediler ki
bu böyle gitmeyecek
Ben seni deliler gazete satıcılığı
verelim kekemeliğim bitsin Sekiz yaşına
bir çocuk düşünün
en
büyük uygarlıklarına
bu nehirlerin küstüğü yerlerde
kurulmuştur bilimde de yaratıcılık kesip
dinlerin kesiştiği yerde
en başta
abone ol
18 yaşındaki çocuk be Bir insanın
büyüklüğü söyledikleri yaptıklarına şu
ortadaki gayrım üstünde çıkar ağzında
olan
makine ustası
Şansıma Düştü ondan öğrendikleri mno3 ne
yaptın Allah cennetini mekan eylesin
bana hayatta yapmıyorum
O benim bu hayatımda en büyük özelliği
Burunun
çalışanların hepsini gördüğünüz bu
insanların o devirde okuma-yazma bilmesi
Ya ben sabahleyin 7'de matbaayı
gidiyorum Ustam da kahvaltı yapıyorum
kıymalı poğaça peynirli poğaça
bu odasının temizliyorum önlü orada
gidiyorum okula gidiyorum Okuldan
çıkıyorum geliyorum
gazetenin ödediği para ile Lokantada
yemek yiyorum ama öyle bir şeref ki o
büyüklerin arasında bir çocuk o
Herkes orada gazetede oluyorum Gece kaça
kadar kaçtılar biterse satıyorum hiçbir
gazete iade etmedim hayatım
ama en büyük mutluluğu kv-2 sıcak ekmek
götürmek
En sonunda bu hayatımda Benim 11 Sn bu
şekilde devam etti kardeşim
bu gazete Sultanbeyli
Ama bu yaşında gençler biterken okumaya
devam ediyorum ama matbaa gelen
büyüklerden çok şey kokuyor çok onları
dinliyor konuşmadığım için de seviyorum
hayatında hep dinlemek nasip etti bana
arada Ama tek geçince
olgun bir insan nasıl olur olgun insan
kendi zekâsına aklını cüret eden insan
Bunu ancak tembeller ve korkaklar
yapamaz ben kendimi olgun olarak gördüm
Kendi Kendime karar verdim ben gazeteci
matbaacı olacak altın bileziğin var
bak bak bağlı Yazı yazıyordum Türkiye'de
en büyük gazetesinin Kocaeli mi ağabey
ve Biraz zaman geçince Okul bitince de
yazı işleri müdürü oldu gazeteler
röportajlar yapıyoruz
ama kendi açından da ben artık hukukçu
gazeteci olacak
geçimini temin edebilecek güce geldim
Çünkü patrondan sonra iki oldum şu
Ha bu arada bir doktor İngiltere tavsiye
Görmüş Çok tatlı bir insandı
arkadaşlarına gelip sohbetlerinde dedi
ki keşke dediği zaten olsun
bak bak eczacılığa girdim O zaman
üniversite saldırayım
bu eczacıoğlu bugün böyle dolaşıyorum
hocam gördü abi olacağım Ne oldu tamam
dedi hocam dedim hukuku kazandım
eczacılıkta kazandım ama eczacılığın
devam et sürekli var Mahallesi Gizemi
için dedi ben seni okuttum
Adem hocam ben oldu
abone ol
bu ve üniversiteye başladım üniversitede
başladığım sıralarda
da gayet iyi gidiyordu otelde kalıyordum
otelde çalışıyordum öğreniyordum Akşam
olunca da Karşıya gidiyorum Türkiye'nin
en büyük gazete süt kesildi yerimiz
cağaloğlu'nda öteki ya gidiyordum
Ordu'da Lokantası şu an et yemekleri
bedava orada büyüklerde ve mesleğini
daha iyi etmeye çalışıyoruz
üniversite son sınıfa kadar geldiğimde
bir aile bir sebebi de evlenmeye karardı
bu kader hiç düşünüyorum İzmit'ten
ayrılacak karar ver
bu sıktık arkadaşlarım baktım Eczacı
olsun biraz daha iyi olsun diye ama
sonunda
Evet hocam aşık ol
Ben söylemem imkansız ay fıkraları
öğreniyordum gazete gelip laboratuvarda
anlatıyoruz bir gün anlatırken kahkaha
içindeydi kimse yoktu ve Artık kontrol
eder hocam görmüş
mı geldi Sen yaptığın nedir dedi gel koy
üstüne göreceğim seni
git tüm dedi Okulda en çok sevilen para
ve Sensin bütün hocalar Sana Hayran ne
oldu Sen de huyum değiştirdi hocam dedim
aşık oldum
o odaya çıktık
bu dosyanın içine bir kağıt çıkar
üniversitede albümdeki bizdeki yazılan
hakkımızda yıkılan yazıları ocakları
verirlerdi oradan oldu benim hakkımda
yazılan yazıyı oku dedi
birazcık okudu Orada yazıyor ki at ama
yarın öbür gün
gazetelerde boy boy resmini görürseniz
şaşırmayın
marketlerde çıkacak diye kitabında var
var ama dediğimizde sekreter olacakmış
özet
ve hala Bak ben dedim ki hocam
Ya kusura bakmayın varsa Aşık başladım
ağlamaya
ya bir kuruş param yok
Ne Anam Var babam yok çünkü dedim anımı
almak zorundayım Askerliğimi yapmadım
derste çalışamıyorum sizin yüzünüzden
dedi
bu birazcık yumuşadı sonra döndü yaşın
kaç dedi
var ya şunu söyledi
bir tuvalete geldi Ama ben seninle
evleneceğim
bu ama Telli duvaklı gelirim Benim
aşireti kızıyım Obam kapalı çalışırım en
büyük Kuyumcusu bir sana vermezler benim
milletvekili ile evlendirmek istiyorlar
Türk filmi aldı Ben seninle evlenirim
dedi ama çok zorluk çekeceksin
ama biz evlendik 26 yaşında
bu işte gazetelerde bütün manşetleri
çıktım 74 tane gazete Dünyam eğitimi
aldı 20 yıl sonra
bu ve farklı iş deneyimlerim faydaları
26 yaşında evlendim 32 yaşında
bir gazetede yazıyor zaten kendi
gösterdi ya fabrikası
ve Trakya'nın en büyük Gazetesi ve vergi
rekor
ben kaldım mı Zühtü vergi rekortmeni
oldu çünkü Vatanımı milletimi çok
seviyorum
bu ve bu başarıdan sonra
üniversiteye geldiğim gün bir sokak tip
girdiğim gibi ben Galatasaray bir
grubumuz vardı O grubun size bize garip
takı mıydı
var ama 5-6 çocuk vardı o 5-6 çocuk
Eve gittin mi Anlıyorum Siz nerede
okudunuz dedim Galatasaray Almanya sesi
Robert Kolej
dediler farklı köprü o gün yemin
etmiştim ben adam olursan çocuklar bu
mutlu olacağım ben de insan bilmiyorum
İki evladım var Allah razı olsun
tuttuğunu altın etsin İkisi de üçer
Bence abi
Sen bana uyuz derler şu fazla gördüğünüz
bozukluğu 50 liralık bozuk ama değil
siyah bakın gölgeye
Ben Hollanda kral ve kraliçe sini
o resmi iki buçuk milyon dola işte
girişi müdürlük Bu bakış açısı bu ve
arzu Aşk tuttu disipline İnsanların
yaptığı iş
her türlü düğün ayakkabı kırmızı şartta
bakın ayakkabısı
bu sokakta gittiğimde gazete kağıdına
hesap yapıyorlardı gazetenin düşünün
kenarda ve ortalarda lokanta sahibi
hesapları orada yapar Ben Matbaadan
artık kağıtları aldım verdim O
bu ve savcının bunlara yazma kağıda yaz
ne yaptım 1 2 3. sebze tabi tümünün
kanun doymuyor bana 4 köftenin altı
köfte ver çorbanın yoldaki köfte var bir
tuvalete olur sonra blok yaptım pozisyon
yaptım bütün dünya gördü Bütün
Türkiye'ye sap Zengin oldum on yaşından
sonra Ailemden bir kuruş para almadım
o Türkiye'nin ilk kez tamindir makinesi
kendime dinlerinde yaptım elektrik Ağrı
20 metrekare fabrika dünyanın en büyük
ıslak mendil fabrikası
beni Okutan ana Limanı
fabrikanın kapısına girişine Alim anımı
yazdım zeka insanda vardır ama Vefa
insan olan Dadı Rayban bütün kapıların
Ayaz
Evet şu gördüğünüz kokular sezon dünyada
biz keşfi ailece şu turşu biz onun
gördünüz mü turşu bir doğru musluk
taktık
o ilk başladığımız tek bir ayda 20 tane
olur şu süngerle son dünyada biz yaptık
Amerika'ya her ay bir milyon tane
veriyor 68 ülkeye ihracat yapıyordu Bir
de formülü de sattım Ayıp olmaz saç
polisi bir hastanın yakılmasıyla dünyada
ilk pasta borusunun Yani hasta yaparak
hastalığı çok duasını aldım ve Burada
gördüğünüz saçmalık lütfen ileri yap
Ben 20 yıl eve
ve dezenfekte almaya geliyor artık
bendemiz oldu herkes ağa dedi
Ben 20 yıl eve
bu dünyada en şeffaf topunu biz yaptık
sosyeti işini olmadı yani oldu da asıldı
içine oyuncak koydum çocuklar yıkasınlar
Troy sanat'ta her ay bir milyon tane
bir milyon
ve bu hayattaki en çok dikkat ettim iki
husus vardır 10 sayı söyleyeceğim bu
yirmi beş yıl evvelki yazılıdır
fabrikanın içinde müessesemizde zaman
altındır zamanı çalan hırsız durdu
insanlar dünyanın parasını versin zamanı
geldi getiremez
bu Eğer bir insan Kendi hayatındaki
zamanı çalıyorsa
kendisine en büyük kötülüğü yok
ve buradaki insanın yaşantısında
gördüğünüz gelişmiş ülkelerde üç buçuk
yıllık on yıl falan al dünya Eğer bir
insan son altı Günay kullanıyorsa 40'ına
kadar merdivenleri çıkarken terlemezse
Kırkından Sonra inersen hüngür olmaz
bunlar hep hayatlarında Şikayetini eden
insanlar
ikincisi bu internet şu anda Eğer
dünyayı bilmiyorsan dünyanın maskarası
olur onlar cesaretsiz aptal
bu ve korkaklar üçüncüsü de mirasyediler
dir 25 yaşında ben çok üniversite
arkadaşım 25 yaşında ölmüş 75'in de
gömülmüştü bunlarda mirasyediler çok
konuşuyorlar iyi giyinirler
bayılırsınız ama yangını yaklaşmayın Bir
de vardır ki bu üç buçuk yıl eğitimi
dediğimiz hayatımızda çalışanlar var
bu azimle hırsla da zevkle Ömer aklı
çalışanlar muhakkak adam olacak
o kadar eşim kanser ol
o o o eşimin kanser olmasıyla hayatı
uzmanlığı dedim ki dünyaya nasıl geldin
çıplak geldim çıplak gideceksin değmez
mi buçuk bu hayat çok değer çok şeyler
kalktı Ama benim bazı şüphelerim artık
hiçbir şey götürelim için Çünkü benim
uçurdu Kartallar gibi kanadımı gitti
eşim olmayınca hayatın tadı kaçtı ve
eşim rahmetli olduktan sonra başkaları
yabancılar çok büyük paralar verdiler
Allah'ın sürekli vaka belli tane markam
Türkiye'de kalsın diye
bu Türkiye'de satılık ucuz minicik
satıraltı da
ya Ben hayatımda
ülkeme ve kurumlarına çok borçlusun
Ben anneme babama çok zor Sen beni gece
can veren yemeyip gezilen içmeyen tren
Sen bana iyi insan olmayı öğreten Obama
ölmüştü gerçek arama çok olsun
O benim okuldan öğretmenlerine Çok
borçluyum
bu Eşme Anadolu Lisesi açtım Trakya'nın
en büyük
okuldur en güzel okul dur ve oradaki
hocaları elimden geldiği kadar her gün
bu elimden geleni yapıyorum o kadın o
insan
ve o varlıklı içinde üç tahta sandalye
açılıp yapalım yemek masasına geldi
44001 gün var o zenginim de mi
şu an Ama baktı Ben hayatımda
fabrikamızda 500 kişi çalışıyordu 25
kişilik idare ettin de geldiğince vakit
ben maalesef ayağa kalkıp değil severek
yerim onu verir bir erkeğin arkasında
kadın yoktur eşi vardır önünde bak 44
yıl eşmenler daim olmak için çalıştım
Oh
be onu benim için
hayatımda
başarımda yüzdeyüz katkısı olsun
Bu
noktadan almanın kütüphaneler yapıyorum
o laboratuvarlar
bu ipim tahta kaşıkla evden Doğan iki
kardeş bugün iki caddede ismimiz vardır
onlar versem yaptırmam
Bu vatanın ve bu tekirdağlıların ve
İzmit leri sonsuz sonsuz borçluyuz
bu gençliğimde Benim çektiğim in
çekmesin diye bir sürü para Beyler
okutuyorum Allah
bölgelerinde yaşadım inşallah
ve bu Türk milletini
[Müzik]
de bakmış Bütün her tarafı işgal edilmiş
ve
sonsuz bir halde mahvolmuş büyük şeyi o
kendi ülkesinden sürülmüş yetim
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'e ve Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nin demokrasini Kur'an
şahsına sonsuz şükranlarını labor
suçluyum biçim dostum
Hayatta en hakiki bir his dediğimiz bir
bilimdir bu sus hiçbir şey olamaz Eğer
inancının sözünüz varsa yada Hayal
denizden asla vazgeçmiyor sanız beni
dinlediğiniz için sizlere de sonsuz
şükranlarımı istiyorum sağlığınız aldım